welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and while doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness trailers seem to
show doctor strange placed under arrest
by the mcu illuminati is it really dr
strange's fault for breaking the
multiverse i mean sure yeah doctor
strange not the most responsible of
sorcerer's apprentices but i don't think
we here at new rockstars would be doing
our due diligence if we didn't analyze
all the suspects and after magic curious
george the most likely culprit is of
course westview's reality warping which
he warden wanda maximoff herself so
let's party like in 1662 and start a
witch trial in this [ __ ] my nerd
babies
because in the criminal justice system
the people are represented by two
separate but equally important groups
the speculation nation who investigate
crime and the bald mind readers of the
illuminati who prosecute the offenders
these are their stories
this video is sponsored by story blocks
more on them later okay so i believe
that one of wanda's biggest crimes to
the overall health and safety of all the
citizens of the multiverse comes from
this moment in the newest multiverse of
madness trailer where we see this shot
of awanda seemingly consoling another
variant of herself within the very same
home that wanda built for her and her
imaginary family in one division now you
may be thinking come on now mt give your
girl wanda a break all right her mommy
dead her daddy dead her virtuous
vibranium vibrator also dead like can a
girl just cross a multiverse or two to
do a little self-care i mean if loki and
zilby can make out in front of a kooky
spooky weirdo then why is it somehow a
crime to dry your own eye huh it doesn't
seem fair well hold on now we gotta ask
ourselves what in irishm's holy name are
these two nexus beings doing in the same
place
because i do declare that in the marvel
comics that's a violation because not
only do we know that nexus beings are
the literal walking cosmic anchors of
their realities but 1994 scarlet witch
number four also establishes that two
nexus beings cannot physically exist in
the same dimension at the same time so
if these two nexus anchors of their own
respective realities are meeting this
could explain why all these wonky holes
in reality have started to open up
because these two anchors got too close
together causing their respective
universes to clash but comic books aside
remember when the term nexus was first
dropped during one division episode 7's
fake commercial break you know the one
with the nexus pill that was directly
marketed to nexus beings who were one
feeling depressed two feeling like the
world was going on without them and
three wanted to be left alone the pill
that could anchor you back to your
reality or the reality of your choice
well this could be what is happening in
this scene with our wanda being that
pill for the depressed scarlet witch
variant on the ground who seemingly just
went through her own version of one
division trauma because you gotta
remember wanda vision ended with wanda
maximoff in possession of the dark hope
desperately tearing through that
tantalizing tome of terror for any way
that she could resurrect her beloved
dead children billy won division and
tommyward division that's their full
name on their birth certificate i saw i
was there well i i was just i was behind
the stork
so there is a chance that we could be
looking at a scenario where our wanda is
using the dark knowledge of the dark
hold the same dark hole darkness that
drove agatha harkness mad enough to be
executed by her own mother to desecrate
multiple realities of the multiverse by
looking for other wanda maximoff nexus
variants who were just as desperate and
broken as her at the end of one division
for the specific purpose of absorbing
them into her being much like strange
supreme absorbed all of those mystical
creatures into his being in what if and
this could also be why we see this image
of what appears to be prison cells after
the sam raimi zoom in on wanda's eyes in
the trailers these could be magical
mental holding cells for the wanda nexus
variants that she has either convinced
or kidnapped to add to her own power
like they're literally chilling inside
of her being her body her head and after
having just absorbed centuries worth of
magic from a being who spent her entire
super long life absorbing the magic of
others agatha could have created the
very prophecy that she was worried about
by giving wanda access to this new
hunger through this experience and this
new knowledge through the darkhold and
with one division establishing that the
scarlet witch is capable of building a
reality desecrating hex bubble around
westview new jersey she might actually
want to feast on at least a couple of
scarlet witch variants so that she could
have the hex cover the entire world
finally giving us the house of m
scenario that we've always wanted to see
in the mcu but likely not without the
reality shattering consequences that we
see in the trailer making the type of
high quality video content that people
fall in love with is time consuming
story blocks saves you time and helps
you make your videos that much more
lovable the storyblocks membership is
essential for any creator and thanks to
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
they have a huge library full of 4k and
hd footage after effects in premiere pro
templates music images and sound effects
to bring your stories to life the assets
are royalty free so you can use your
downloaded content anywhere for
commercial and personal use check out
the unlimited all access plan which
gives you unlimited downloads of the
over 1 million assets in their library
and choose a plan that works for you
from their selection of flexible
subscriptions at scale to give you all
the content and tools you need to focus
on creating and not worrying about
budget and if you're a member of a large
creative team marketing agency or just
media organization their enterprise
license has your back with comprehensive
coverage for your entire company that
enables you to distribute wherever
whenever go to storyblocks.com new
rockstars now or click the link in the
description box below to check out their
unlimited all-access plan today once
again thank you to storyblocks for
sponsoring this video but hey speaking
of that reality desecrating hex bubble
that's another crime because of course
everything wanda did within west view in
one division was definitely a violation
of mordo's beloved natural law i mean
hell wanda was literally rearranging the
very molecules of everything and
everyone within westview even monica
rambo's clothes became bulletproof after
her kevlar vest merged with her clothes
can i borrow this whoa whoa whoa whoa
you had a bulletproof vest on when you
went inside didn't you those pants are
87 kevlar
it's not an illusion wanda is rewriting
reality and so far monica is like the
only person that we know about that was
cosmically altered by the scarlet
witch's new jersey freakout so what if
her chaos magic affected more people
because that is highly likely especially
with miss marvel on the way because many
have suspected ms marvel's powers to be
linked to wanda's hex in one division as
ms marvel is from new jersey herself so
it wouldn't be out of the question for
wanda to have created a villain or two
that threads the safety of her entire
reality from these events of wanda
vision because who knows how many people
from new jersey are evil probably a lot
and also hey uh remember franklin you
know that sword agent that was looking
for sewer bees and wanda maxim offices
before wanda wiped him out of the face
of existence you do great because nobody
else does like i'm no matt murdock but
i'm pretty sure obliterating a man with
a family from reality and causing all of
his co-workers to forget his birthday
and also his birth might be a tad bit
illegal but also potentially problematic
on a multiversal scale because as we saw
from no way home after the dark
affiliated magic of the ruins of call
memory spell caused holes in reality to
open up wanda having the power to
manipulate memories to a similar degree
could be further breaking down the
stability of mcu's reality especially if
the darkhold is somehow allowing her to
increase in power by collecting all
these scarlet witches or just you know
any powerful chaos magic user like i
suspect defender strange will be in the
movie but finally in terms of wanda's
cosmic crimes though she technically
didn't even want to do this wanda kind
of destroyed the mine stone at one point
which has been a staple of the mcu
cosmos for eons before wanda ever
pinched a paprika with a british
sithazoid okay however with what we know
about the nature of the infinity stones
is that they are not supposed to be able
to be destroyed with odin saying as much
about the reality stone in thor 2. so
want to maximoff briefly destroying the
indestructible using her unpredictable
chaos magic only for thanos to make a
similar universal paradox through the
mindstone's destruction again
could have been enough to tear a bunch
of holes in reality for sure because
that's not supposed to happen but those
are just the major reality ruining
crimes of one wanda maxima do you think
it was actually wanda who was the one
who broke the mcu multiverse or with
somebody else in the mcu or maybe
somebody that we haven't even seen yet
let us know in the comment section below
so we can do some more deep law and
order mcu dives together my beautiful
nerd babies because i love doing these
this is fun but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some really
weird [ __ ] follow new rockstars wherever
we are on social media and on youtube
make sure you hit the notification bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a new video and make sure to
hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can
find all of our cool shirts especially
our new batman inspired shirts because
batman is amazing i just saw it and you
guys are going to see this because it is
one of the coolest things i've ever seen
but again thank you guys for watching
this video i love you guys so much and
i'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]